Speaker 1: . We have a voicemail number.
That number is 2192. David P. Unfortunately,
there are people we launched the David Pakman
Show Finance Channel were right at the cusp of
10,000 subscribers on it already. YouTube.com
slash pacman finance. It's a beautiful
channel. It's financial education. But
someone seems confused about what the
channel actually is.
Speaker 3: David
Regarding your financial advising YouTube
channel, I distinctly recall you saying,
sir, that people should tune in and you would
tell them exactly how to invest every dollar
that they have. And you are a financial genius
and you have made great money in doing this. I
remember you saying that. And by the way, I'm just
kidding. I'm so sick of your reading comprehension
challenged conservative listeners. I now call
in and think they got you because they made up
something in their head. It's driving me nuts.
AJ Come on, people. Good God. I mean, this is
even actually reading comprehension. Listening,
listening comprehension. Yeah. But now we can
see why they're so easily exploited by. That's
the conservative sheep, not you exploiting them.
Thanks for the fun stuff. Have a good weekend.
I'm just calling. This isn't too lazy to write.
Speaker 1: All right, very good. And again, I am
not giving anyone specific financial advice on the
Pokemon Finance YouTube channel, but we do have a
ton of education topics. You can find the channel
at YouTube.com, slash, pacman, finance. We are
like within 20 subscribers of 10,000. So if you
want to be one of the first 10,000, check it out.
Recent clips include What is your net worth? How
do you simply create a basic personal balance
sheet to figure out what is your net worth?
Why is it that we have seen a declining
stock market over the last several months?
What factors influence that? How do you improve
your credit score? Why you should not try to time
the market? That's one of the most popular clips
and most controversial. I don't think you should
try to time the market. I don't think it's really
doable for the average person. And quite frankly,
even most money managers failed to correctly
time the market. A lot of really good stuff.
No politics on the channel. Okay, that's
youtube.com slash pacman finance. I hope that
you will all join me on today's bonus show.
Speaker 2: Oh, the bonus show where you
want to make money and everybody else that makes
money to fund themselves is bad.
Speaker 1: Well, yeah, I mean, we're
funded by the audience. So in a sense, it's true
that with a bonus show makes money. Okay, Alex,
you can sign up at join Pacman dot com. We will
talk about job openings plunging in August. Is
that a good sign or a bad sign? There's two ways
to interpret that. A michigan judge has dropped
felony charges against seven people in the Flint
water scandal. And a U.S. appeals court has sent a
Dacca case back to a lower court to consider
a new rule and the implications for docket
recipients are significant. All of those stories
and more on today's bonus show, Don't Miss.